from a crossover death match to a DC
do-over these PG-13 movies received
R-rated sequels that were more violent
more intense and more profane the
Riddick franchise has been an
interesting one indeed it was kicked off
by the surprise action horror hit hits
black in 2000 one of the movies that
helped put Vin Diesel on the map before
his debut is Dominic Toretto the
following year Diesel and director David
Tui decided to expand the Riddick
Universe via the more ambitious and
lower heavy The Chronicles of Riddick
but what started out as an R-rated
franchise had to become a PG-13 one in
order to convince Universal to give them
the nine-figure budget they needed even
though Chronicles was a box office flop
Diesel and Tui remained passionate about
the Riddick character and universe and
they teased a third film for years not
satisfied with the creative sacrifices
that had to be made in order for
Chronicles to be PG-13 diesel said he
was determined to have the third
installment simply titled Riddick be R
rated by the original movie and not have
any of the restraints that a lower
rating would put on the project it took
nine years and Diesel having to leverage
his house to get it funded but Riddick
was finally released in 2013 with its
intended R rating intact all you people
are so scared of me
most days that take that as a compliment
although some of the smaller imprints
are willing to push the envelope much
further most Marvel and DC Comics keep
things within what can best be described
as PG territory there's occasionally
blood some bad words and brief glimpses
of Flesh from time to time but you'll
very rarely see more than that in
mainstream comic book wives 2013's The
Wolverine was a standard PG-13 entry
into the superhero Canon with a decent
box office take and solid reviews but
Deadpool changed the game in 2016 when
it became the highest grossing R-rated
movie ever made at the time of its
release this sent the message to Studios
that audiences would show up in huge
numbers for R-rated comic book movies
and it definitely emboldened the 20th
Century Fox in particular to let its
Wolverine Trilogy go out in a blaze of
gory Glory the following year star Hugh
Jackman was so committed to having
2017's Logan be rated R that he was
willing to take a pay cut to compensate
for the lower budget that R-rated movies
typically get by default Logan not only
went on to become one of the high
highest grossing R-rated movies of all
time but it was the first superhero
movie to ever be nominated for a
screenwriting Oscar although there had
been some earlier R-rated comic book
movie adaptations like blade and the
crow the genre moved pretty firmly into
PG and PG-13 territory around the turn
of the Millennium even the DC extended
Universe which attempted to set itself
apart from the MCU by being the home of
Darker prettier comic book movies stayed
in PG-13 land for the first few years of
its existence Margot Robbie spent
several years trying to get an R-rated
Harley Quinn spin-off movie made
following her debut as the character in
the 2016 movie Suicide Squad it
certainly can't be a coincidence that
birds of prey and its R rating came a
year after the massively successful 2019
R-rated Joker Standalone film starring
Joaquin Phoenix the well received in
very adult Harley Quinn HBO animated
series that also debuted in 2019 may
have been a factor as well even though
Birds of Prey didn't quite break even at
the box office this critical reception
was largely positive unlike the 2016
effort that film certainly helped to
pave the way for the half sequel half
reboot the suicide squad released in
2021 which was also rated R uh what
she's a javelin I'm waiting for God to
tell me Jesus Christ yeah or him or any
of them really
Terminator 2 Judgment Day remains one of
the greatest action films of all time
and it's held up remarkably well for a
movie that's now more than 30 years old
that's why it's so disappointing just
how badly the franchise lost its way
after its underrated third installment
Terminator 3 rise of the Machines soft
reboot Terminator Salvation failed to
live up to its predecessors and was
released with a notable lack of Arnold
Schwarzenegger even though Arnie
returned for Terminator Genesis that
movie Saw the franchise get even further
away from the greatness that it was once
known for one problem was that both
salvation and Genesis went the PG-13
route in an effort to appeal to a wider
audience an odd move considering that T2
and T3 both did just fine with our R
ratings attached when James Cameron
rejoined the franchise for the first
time since T2 to co-write the story for
Terminator dark fate also bringing back
Linda Hamilton for the first time since
that same movie the R rating was back as
well dark fate director Tim Miller
didn't mince words when he told a
Comic-Con crowd the DNA of Terminator is
an R-rated movie so do not do it R seems
disingenuous to the source material why
not just let me have
because we're not machines you metal
[__]
unfortunately despite the consensus that
dark fate finally got the ailing
franchise back on track creatively
audiences had been too badly burned by
previous installments and didn't show up
for it even action movies aren't exempt
from the tendency to try and stay PG in
order to maximize box office potential
it's unlikely that the target audience
for a mixed martial arts movie about a
gritty underground Fight Club is going
to contain too many people that can't
get into an R-rated film but
nevertheless Never Back Down was
released with a PG-13 rating in 2008. it
didn't set the box office on fire but it
made a profit against its modest budget
and did well enough for at least a
directive video sequel once at
theatrical run is taken out of the
equation ratings become much less
important so it's very common for a
series to get a lot edgier content-wise
as such Never Back Down 2 the Beatdown
the directorial debut of prolific
martial arts actor Michael Jai White
went R-rated and never looked back
they're repetitively titled third
installment Never back down no surrender
again directed by white who also
co-wrote the story was also rated R as
was its fourth entry revolt few movie
franchises have had as triumphant to
return after both a long Hiatus and a
poorly received entry as Mad Max did
with the nearly Flawless Mad Max Fury
Road it was a rare example of a movie
being a wall-to-wall action spectacular
while still managing to be critically
acclaimed even becoming nominated for a
Best Picture Oscar those accomplishments
are impressive enough on their own but
even more so considering that the movie
followed up the franchise's low point
the extremely disappointing Mad Max
Beyond Thunderdome two men enter
one man leaves
after the surprising success of Mad Max
and its sequel the road warrior a third
installment was a foregone conclusion
surprisingly Beyond Thunderdome being
tagged PG-13 after two R-rated
predecessors wasn't done so more money
would be spent on the film it still cost
about 10 million dollars in actuality
director George Miller was grieving the
loss of producing partner Byron Kennedy
who died while scouting locations for
Beyond Thunderdome Miller decided to
push on with the movie regardless which
is likely why Beyond Thunderdome ended
up with its softer tone when Miller
finally returned to the franchise
decades later he was ready to make a
properly R-rated Mad Max movie once
again it can be debated all day long
which WWE wrestler turned actor has done
the best job at making that transition
in terms of box office receipts Dwayne
Johnson is tough to beat at the same
time Dave Bautista seems to be getting a
lot of people on his side as the one
with the strongest acting chops but it
wouldn't be fair to count out John Cena
just yet as he slowly carving out his
own successful acting path and deserves
to also be part of that conversation
Cena's first starring role in a movie
was in 2006's the Marine which didn't
get any Critics on his side but did well
enough at the box office to launch a
prolific filmography of both movie and
TV roles in fact Cena was already too
big of a star by the time the first
Marine sequel was underway to reprise
his role with the lead instead going to
fellow WWE wrestler Ted DiBiase Jr the
directive video movie also went from
PG-13 to r as it upped the ante with
more violence more foul language and
more skin this approach apparently
worked for the Marine too as for further
installments of the series from The
Marine 3 home front to final entry the
Marine six Close Quarters retained the R
rating the original Die Hard might not
be the most intense R-rated action movie
ever made but it definitely would have
lost something if it had stayed within
the confines of a PG-13 rating after all
John McLean's catchphrase literally
contains an F-bomb
after its huge success both in theaters
and on home video there was no reason to
tone things down for Die Hard 2 and
after the success of that movie it was a
given that the third installment Die
Hard with a Vengeance would stay R-rated
as well yet when the Die Hard series
returned from a 12-year absence with
2007's Live Free or Die Hard 20th
Century Fox seemed less confident in the
prospects of another R-rated romp and
decided to take things down to PG-13 for
the first time while the result was a
movie that did well with critics its 382
million dollar take in 2007 was
technically a step down compared to the
last films when adjusted for inflation
that meant that there was no reason to
keep McLean's violent tendencies in
pottymouth in check for the next entry A
Good Day to Die Hard that would be the
last Die Hard movie Willis made prior to
his retirement from acting in 2022 every
alien movie was rated R every Predator
movie was rated R so when it came time
for the big crossover movie to happen
surely Alien vs Predator was rated R2
right nope without enough faith that the
two franchises could attract their
longtime fans back to Cinemas it was
decided that The long-awaited Showdown
should take place within the confines of
a PG-13 setting Alien vs Predator was a
disappointment by almost every metric
but it was still too promising of an
idea to let die after just one misstep
thankfully a follow-up was released in
2007 that at least understood what a No
Holds Barred R-rated beat down between
the iconic Rivals would look like sure
Aliens vs Predator Requiem was panned
even harder than the previous film did
worse at the box office and put plans
for future entries on indefinite hold
but at least it was R-rated like it
deserved to be so that's something as
for the individual franchises Predator
came back strong in 2022 with the
critically acclaimed prequel prey while
original alien director Ridley Scott
finally returned to his Universe in the
2010s with Prometheus and alien Covenant
it would seem that the two franchises
are better off alone R-rated or
otherwise
foreign